[Music]
good morning gamers
whoa we're almost there
it's time for the woodland mansion
whoa it's dark oh god this could be it
i'm not gonna lie this could be it let's
do a quick sleep
cause tomorrow we fight though
i have never done this in hardcore mode
obviously
i don't know what the stratus i need my
instant health ready
i should drink the strength potion what
else do we need did i not bring a shield
cool okay
it's cool i've never seen it spawn in
water before
oh god i don't want to this up
all right let's drink the potion let's
start with the 8-minute one i think it
gets harder and harder
[Music]
all right we're going in gamers
oh god i hear them all why are we
starting off with the dead end
should we just open up hello
[Music]
hello oh
well they die fast i don't like hearing
them
apparently these are not called caldrons
they're called cauldrons
which makes absolutely no sense i just
wanted to make that clear
oh that's another room isn't it hello
[Music]
okay as long as they don't hit me i
should be okay damn i do a lot of damage
so these are all empty aren't they yeah
i hear a guy in here
that's a creeper i want to make sure i
don't turn my back on anything
that's how they get you they stab you in
the back i don't know what's the strat
do i cover up the rooms
that i got jump scared
okay we're good we're good we're good
i got so jump scared
oh my gosh
[Music]
oh oh my god is he invisible
what's hitting me
what's hitting me what was that
i just give me eat it is that a thing
that can become invisible and i don't
know about it
i can't believe it my stomach hurts i
thought i was a goner dude
was that a glitch like what was that i
know spiders become invisible
oh now i'm nervous dude
yeah i hear them you see invisible
it's a invisible mob dude and he
does so much damage
can i hit him at least let me check is
it glitched
he was glitch dude holy
oh my god i am angry
that is mojang
i couldn't even hit him dude oh i'm so
angry
all right we keep going let's hope that
never happens again
all right we got a lot of rooms to go
through no more babying around
any more invisible damn a lot of
a lot of things dark oh maybe worth
getting a full
stack i've never seen this many
mine this is mine now people keep saying
that you shouldn't plant dark oak
because it attracts mobs but the
but the but the the wood itself should
be fine right
all right let's keep going
nice it's just death traps everywhere i
i like it i keep hearing them here and i
don't understand why
hello here's a hidden room
with a creeper in it
and efficiency x guys it was worth the
trip
oh my gosh more dude i can have one more
all right we got a sack look how much
did they drop all this or did i had
already some
i think we're done with the bottom floor
if i remember correctly it gets harder
as
uh my strength potion is already out
dude
let's drink another one
a little banner
also a lot of hidden chests and while
speaking of which
diamond hoe yes
what okay all right time to go upstairs
oh i see you
you're not invisible anymore huh they're
slower on the carpet too
never mind on bedrock they are jesus
alright this is where the
the danger begins for real because when
the wrath comes
that's when it gets tough i can't
believe i went all the way without a
shield
that just oh we got books nice i don't
think i need any but
it's always good because you get so many
here
let's check in here surprisingly few
enemies
i saw you got these little beds
cute
pink beds i'm not afraid of anyone that
sleeps in a pink bed
you know what i think i'll sleep myself
there's probably too many enemies there
but yeah i don't know why i thought that
was a good idea
ah this is risky busy
okay so i have 44 okay they dropped two
two emeralds it's dark now
makes it a little scarier i've already
been close to dying once
doesn't feel good i'm not going to lie
oh i see you see oh i hear someone
so spiders spawn apparently on hardcore
i didn't know this with a random buff
that's why one of them was uh invisible
he does not give a freak dude
good for me i'll take it that's how
we're gonna deal with the wrath i'm not
gonna
i don't know hello
all right we got more books i keep
hearing them but like
that's the wrath no it isn't yeah
no it isn't
whoa holy
the potion of strength was a good call
dude there it is let's kill it fast
okay okay now these they do so
much damage
oh god this is a scarce moment
there's another wrath
they do so much damage
okay one down two down
okay nice nice there's one more
two more nice
clean let's get the other breath
real fast i don't want him to keep
spawning yeah
there we go yeah okay excellent there's
three already
these are such pain in the ass
dude
whoa oh my god there's so many
[Music]
it seems better to take the offense on
these
oh my god they keep coming oh my god
jesus i hate them
[Music]
oh my god my hell
you let's go kill that
oh my god there's so many
they i've killed like 50 of these
i think i might have to just run in and
kill the rat because these guys are
going to keep spawning right
that was clean big look how many they
are
i don't think i have a choice this is
ridiculous i'm going i'm going in gamer
i'm going in gamers i'm going in gamers
oh it's bad
there's another wrath that's why are you
serious
oh oh my personal strength is that
i actually hate them
whoa there's so many i did not expect it
to be this difficult
there's so many
oh half health
less than half they keep
spawning this is ridiculous
this is fine
they're coming from the
everywhere
i'm done can they go in water
this is so tough dude i've been
half health
less than half health like three times i
don't feel great about this
i don't know what to do oh jesus
all right night
at least in the open they're a lot
easier to fight
because they don't swiggle wiggle
i'm drinking this and i'm just going in
that guy need to die
you oh my god that was so much easier to
just kill him right away
speed run yeah there are more i just
heard it where
where are you where is he where the
is he
okay i would assume somewhere here
it's in a hidden room or something why
why
is he upstairs somewhere
i hear so many of them
[Music]
jesus
there they are look at them
i almost jumped down there
i almost went in here dude oh okay let's
find a rat
there you are
yes is that
was it that's a cat
i didn't think i'd be speedrunning this
thing
there you are okay we're good we're good
we're good i just need to survive oh
there's one more
[Music]
hmm
oh my god
oh
i saw one of them drop a baby and i
think i would like it
i've seen death flash before my there's
the baby
i'm shaking
minecraft got me shaking i think
i did it
i think that was all of them oh my god
that was brutal oh we got another baby
look guys we got books it was totally
worth it
i can't stop shaking
whoa there's just new surprises
everywhere a
creeper fell from there what's
up kitty
not your fault okay i want to go down
one step because i don't think i killed
them all on the second floor
yeah i know i did i did i did
that looks sick dude there's like a ton
of hidden chests and stuff in here
i actually forgot to bring flint and
steel usually i just burned the whole
place down
maybe if i can find some lava maybe it
dropped in one of the boxes how you
doing up there
you know i'm gonna let homie chill oh my
god baby riding a chicken
sorry baby does there have to be so many
creepers
oh yeah there's so much anvils here but
i think they're already quite broken
but there's lava nice
this place is gonna burn i can't believe
how close i was to dying
dude i'm still shook i was so like
it's one of those things where like you
have no choice but to go in
even though it's so reckless whatever
they call like the little flying things
kept coming and coming and coming coming
coming coming
god damn i had no choice man i had to do
it man
i didn't want to do it man but they kept
doing it to me man
that's the most shook i've been in a
video game in a very long time and
can minecraft did this to me minecraft
all right i think i have enough books i
don't really need anything
i could get them more i could get two
more sexy books actually i might as well
get something out of this visit
there's definitely more hidden chess i
want to try and uncover them
so do they not respawn right i kill them
they're not just going to randomly spawn
more rests and like that because
that happens i'm done okay so this is
the outside
cool how we doing here
i kind of wish it wasn't nighttime right
now but
what are you gonna do let's go to the
roof
let's pour that lava does that
not burn it
is that not how lava works is it too
much wood to burn through
oh it's a lot of winter birthday
yeah come here spider this may be a bad
idea but i just enjoy see
you
yes burn
let it burn let's do the same over here
bye creeper yes
oh my god it's burning fast whoa cause
the lava is still going through
holy oh my god
i need to get out of here do your thing
lava do your thing
whoa look at this massive hole it's
already made all right i'm out i'm
out i'm out
jesus
holy that's where i came
there's another chest nice so it is
working
this is a reward right here follow that
pain
spreads fast
well hello there lava
this is sick oh my god dude
it's so cool i never burnt something
this big my computer can totally handle
it
what they look so cool look how many
chests
we just need to figure out how to grab
them oh my gosh
oh i tried to burn this on my switch
when i played on the nintendo switch and
like nothing happened this is so
sick uh you're not gonna make it brother
there's nothing about skeletons only
women and children i'm afraid
and not even those there's another chest
that one pot made it ah there's water
here
lame that's better
you're gonna burn just die bro
hey remember the entrance
[Laughter]
might be good to bring back some chests
they're quite annoying to me
well hopefully this doesn't burn down
while i'm walking on it
more diamond hoes guys we did it the
most useless item in minecraft
what the why do i have three the
real problem is like
how do i get up to some of these chests
like that one i guess i'll take the
stairs
cool this is the craziest thing i've
looked at in minecraft i don't even know
it doesn't look real
oh god it's still burning all right
let's start grabbing some of these
chests
golden apple name tag all right i'll
take it
i'll take it i use two of golden apples
but you know
it's whatever all right what do you got
yes
oh i already have it dang it i already
have a cat
i was really stoked there for a
minute all right let's two more chests
here we go oh my god
i've never seen it so burnt down
hey diamond armor that's kind of cool
too bad i don't need it
but you know another name tag i'll take
it uh poor cat burn
13. ah dang it whoa enchanted golden
apple that's really rare
hell yeah uh 13 is a really spooky one
what do i sack here
i guess some books what would i prefer
to have 54 books or a diamond hoe i
think
sound this seems more reasonable new
recipe online
what can i make with this all right i
think that's it
you wooden mansion selfie
selfie the weather is going to be
tough as hell dude if if i struggle that
much on woodland mansion
my god dude yo i can't get over how cool
it looks
should just burn it right away okay so
what is the gold
enchanted apple so it's stronger than a
regular golden apple which is already
really good
it gives you 16 extra points of health
fire resistance for 5 minutes and 20
reduced damage for 20 minutes and we got
totem of undying which is the reason i
wanted to come here ironically i almost
had to die
to get it but i got it time
to go the freak home
i'm gonna take a break i'm ending that
episode there
[Music]
i'm done i'm done i'll see you next time
gamers
profess i got the best life it's easy to
see
and 100 million people agree because i'm
mine all day
i'm mine all night
[Music]
till i'm all alone i'm mine all the time
i can't find what i want